muốn giới thiệu chia sẻ cho các bạn cái
mà vấn đề mình gặp phải đó là mình muốn
xuất cái file pdf kiểu như này file pdf
kiểu như này nó có tận 200 hơn 200 trang
và hơn 100 m nên thành ra là các tool
miễn phí trên mạng nó đang không hỗ trợ
bắt phải trả phí nên là mình nghĩ là
mình là dân lập trình như mình sẽ tự
code thì mình tra trên mạng có mấy cái
thư viện để mà ngồi làm xong rồi tìm ra
được vấn đề đó là bản chất là cái file
này là file pdf Đây là hình ảnh Nên là
nếu mà dùng một cái thư viện là pdf to
tex nó không được Bởi vì nó không phải
là chữ mà nó phải nhận diện từ ảnh sang
chữ nên là mình dùng
cái mình Cuối cùng thì mình dùng mấy cái
thư viện xuất này nó TC này Đấy mình sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn nhé thì các bạn lên
đây này các bạn chọn release đây thì
chọn cái phiên bản mới nhất này Tải về
cài các thứ các thứ đấy ví dụ bây giờ
mình thử cài cài lại các bạn xem
next finish thôi Đây mình chấp nhận xóa
đi gỡ đi cài lại
này đấy next next các thứ thứ thì riêng
ở chỗ này thì các bạn nên chọn thêm một
cái là hỗ trợ tiếng ngôn ngữ của các bạn
cần trong trường hợp này mình ngôn ngữ
tiếng Việt đấy để tải thêm đấy các thứ
Ok th đây xong một cái tiếp theo là các
bạn phải dùng thêm cả cái thư viện này
nữa là cái này là cái này là sẽ nhận
diện từ ảnh sang chữ nhưng mà bây giờ
mình cần phải biến file pdf thành ảnh
nữa mình sẽ tải thêm cái này Đấy cái này
cũng tải về giải nén các thứ các thứ thì
mình thực ra mình đã giải nén rồi Mình
đã giải nén ở trong thư mục Download của
mình đấy mình đã giải nén ra xong rồi
các bạn ấn vào các bạn chọn Library này
cái pin này Đấy nó thư viện các thứ thứ
ở đây thì mình copy cái đường dẫn này
kết hợp với cái đường dẫn của cái của
cái vừa nãy mình cài Nếu giả sử các bạn
chưa biết được là cái cài nó nằm ở thư
mục nào thì các bạn dùng thêm cả cái
ting này để tìm nó dễ đấy nó sẽ vừa nãy
mình cài trong thườ mục này này đấy các
bạn thấy copy addp đứng dẫn như này kiểu
thế sau đó thì các bạn sẽ mở Ctrl Panel
này mình đang dùng win 11 nhá nên là có
thể nó sẽ hơi khác một tí nhưng các bạn
chỉ cần tìm cái system này đấy đấy các
bạn sẽ vào Advance system setting này
environment này xong rồi chọn cái p này
đấy các bạn sẽ thêm hai cái đường dẫn
này Thực ra bản chất thêm hai đường dẫn
này để làm gì Để mỗi khi mà các bạn Gõ
cái lệnh liên quan đến cái thằng này hay
liên quan thư viện này các bạn sẽ không
phải gõ lại đầy đủ cái đứng dẫn nó nữa
các bạn chỉ cần gõ tên của cái file này
thôi đấy Nói chung là các bạn sẽ thêm
hai một cái đương dẫn rồi các bạn chèn
hai cái là như này ok rồi cứ ok ok lại
được nhá Sau đó đểm gì đấy để các bạn
Ờ
dùng hai thằng Đan senen đây đây hướng
dẫn này tải này cài đặt này thêm và pass
này Đấy xong rồi các bạn chạy lại lệnh
như này thì nó sẽ ra kiểu
version là được ok
đấy tiếp theo là mình bởi vì là có tận
200 file à 200 trang Tức là mình xuất ra
200 ảnh x từ 200 ảnh đấy xuất ra 200 chữ
nên thh rất là dài nên là mình muốn ghi
một cái lệnh để mà để mà chạy trong kiểu
nó tự động chạy cho mình ấ thì mình cũng
tí mình sẽ CP lệnh cho các bạn đây mình
lệnh trong command bản chất nó là
command pro này xong mình Thực ra lúc
đầu chạy cũng bị lỗi đế mình báo lỗi cho
nó các thứ thứ Thì đấy bây giờ sẽ lệnh
hoàn chỉnh như này và lưu lại file sẽ là
lưu ch bass đây mình sẽ copy này
đấy thì ở đây mình có cái thư mục thư
mục đây cái file của mình Đây nhá Đấy
file của mình đây mình tạo một thư mục
như này Đấy xong mình mình chạy cái lệnh
để mà mình xuất ra được cái thư mục này
thì sẽ lệnh như
xem
cái đy bến file
pdf thành ảnh
sẽ bởi vì cái cái file pdf này mình có
cả dấu cách nên mình sẽ nằm ở trong dấu
nháy như này Đấy sau đó thì mình muốn
cho nó hẳn vào một thư mục là scv vừa
rồi và gạch chéo tên của cái thư mục ảnh
là image như này gạch chéo phát nữa đấy
rồi tên file ả là kiểu inmate xong rồi
010203 gì gì đó xong mình
mình reset này rồi mà nhỉ Đợi mình tí
Đợi mình
mục kia không tồn tại phải tạo Hàn Thư
mục đi sccv đi Có khi là thươ mục không
tồn tại nh nó sẽ báo lỗi
tại nhá image
này À đấy Chắc là do thương mộc không
tồn tại ok ok đấy các bạn thấy nó sẽ ra
được rất nhiều ảnh đúng không ạ Tại
thông bao exit in thì tôi tưởng đã tồn
tại rồi hoặ là không tồn
này để ra một loạt ảnh đúng không ạ Đấy
mình cứ ví dụ trước các bạn thấy thực ra
nhiều lắm Mình cứ ví dụ để các bạn tua
nhanh nha Sau đó thì mình
sẽ kéo xống mình sẽ có cái đoạn lệnh này
Đấy mình tạo một cái thươ mục ở đây là T
hoặc thực ra đôi khi không cần tạo thu
mục đó Vì cái lệnh này của mình là đã hỗ
trợ tạo thu mục Nếu không tồn tại rồi
đấy các bạn chỉn copy thế này Mở cái
file notp lên được new này tạo một cái
thử một cái file nop kiểu như
à à à Thôi cứ chấm tt
đi đấy Mình lưu như này đúng không ạ sau
đó thì mình sẽ đổi đổi đường dẫn thành
chấm bass là
được mình đặt tên nó orc đi cũng được
đấy chấm bass như này Đấy xong mình
à hình như là do cái đường dẫn mình chưa
đổi đường dẫn mình phải như này đúng lỗi
lỗi lỗi lỗi mình lỗi mình đừng dẫn nó là
inmate như này vừa nãy mình thêm chữ add
ở đây mình sửa lại cái này nhá các bạn
thể ấn Open edit in p các bạn sửa lại
cũng được vậy Đứng dẫn nó thêm chữ s như
này được
không cái này nó sẽ có vài cái nó không
đúng là kiểu nó nếu là ảnh hay là cái gì
gì đó nhưng mà có phải về cơ bản về cơ
bản là nó cũng hỗ trợ rất là tốt các bạn
thấy không Nó hỗ trợ tương đối tương đối
rất là tốt rồi nhận diện các thứ các thứ
và quan trọng là miễn phí đúng không ạ
Đấy Các bạn cứ để cắm nó chạy khi nà nó
ngừng thì nó sẽ thông báo nhá sẽ ngừng
sẽ tự động chạy ngừng lại Ok không ạ